you've implemented the mainactivity
wireframes so now we can move on to the
detail activity wireframe this is what
it looks like we have the date the high
and low temperatures and then additional
weather information we also have the
weather icon and the weather forecast
and these line up horizontally build up
the layout XML for this wire frame then
modify the detail fragment so that you
can populate all this information
including these new views while you're
doing that you might as well move the
detail fragment into its own file so
it's separate from the detail activity
before you get started I want to point
out that this layout has information
taking up a lot of vertical space if you
rotate your device into landscape mode
or you have a smaller height device some
of the content could get cut off so
think about how you can make this layout
be vertically scrollable to show you
what I mean I added a couple more lines
of text at the bottom of the layout then
I made the content vertically scrollable
so you could see all the information so
go ahead and make that change to your
layout as well when you're done with all
these steps this is what the app should
look like we don't care about the visual
details now we just want to make sure
the functionality is hooked up so all
the right information is displayed on
screen you can use the code snippets
provided below for helper functions and
strings that you're going to need and
again leaving a placeholder image it's
fine for now